all right and we all love the last word
with Laura Kiely don't any boxes we are
back by the campfire more ludus you with
discussion with my brethren how are you
doing sir doing good this morning got up
felt decently rested got a late video
out last night so if you guys are coming
in from YouTube thanks for tuning in but
ya made a random smoothie Bowl and just
a weird breakfast but got the morning
started now we're here and thank you
Luke for giving us plenty of stuff to
read yesterday again lots of text so we
are good there no it's been the weeks
continue at some point I feel like this
has to actually slow down maybe but they
seem more that they may talk about we've
got a lot to discuss and definitely some
things we can go deep on but I'm doing
pretty good I've been playing remnant
actually in my own playing that what's
that about what's going on there so that
is a very very crude description is Dark
Souls crossed with division really so it
is a third-person shooter but you've got
you've got like the dodge roll but it is
like learning enemy's moves or like
predictable shooting patterns things
like that so you have the enemies that
are gonna be you know larger and slower
and you can kind of figure out how you
want to fight them but some of them
shoot stuff at you but you've also got
weapons but you level up you've got like
a bunch of different traits and levels
you can go through co-op cranks it up to
a whole different level which is bananas
nice oh if you go single-player and then
you jump in somebody else's game it's
like depending on the level of that
person if you're about the same cuz I
played with my brother yesterday a
little bit we were pretty close
undamaged but I played with a buddy of
mine who was like 10 times my level and
oh I felt like I was shooting peanuts
man it was and he was putting in work
but I was I was starting on there so
it's very but it is somehow this fun
little intriguing game you don't always
fight the same bosses I mean my friend's
been through like his game fully got
three other people he's been through
seen different bosses some he like still
a couple that he'd know
he hasn't seen there's like secrets to
it in like the home base area there's
upgrading your character upgrading your
armor different armor different weapons
so it's a game that I somehow just like
I heard about it and I was like let's
check it out and then it sounded fun and
one of my buddies like dude this is
freaking awesome and yeah it's a fun one
like it's it's kind of a perfect
holdover for depending on how much time
you want to put into it but you didn't
put a lot of time or even just a full
playthrough it definitely gave you some
work so I mean when you get to a boss
fight by myself still died like 20 times
on one of them I mean it feels like a
souls in like I'm trying to learn a boss
okay there's this mechanic over here and
then this one so it's been it's been fun
give me that challenge did she need you
I know you love your Souls games so
that's good that little [ __ ] is nice
every so often no you're not gonna have
enough time for like code vain
okay oh yeah I forgot about the games
just coming out shout the slow-motion
September September is insane man the
only good thing about it right now is
that we kind of right at that period so
if you got your master work stuff done
for the most part you can't in a chill
zone for the most part you know all me
it's been op opposite it's like I've
been this weird somewhere I shouldn't be
playing as much as I am but I'm like in
this like collectors mode that I need to
be ready for shadow keep for all
scenarios so just when collecting cuz
you got some check boxes you're trying
to hit us yeah man I know me you talk we
gonna get I got to finish off a mask
work stuff but I like it maybe two
pieces lead to shatter throne stuff
whatever but right now it's been I
didn't realize how close I was to
Izanami yeah and I never really got that
done finished and then on crucible some
crucible stuff I've been working on
obviously my on top and now I might wait
till Tuesday if you weren't there
don't rush it but I was already done so
yeah so you got that and um yeah just
various like it's been different little
um like what delirium get knocked all
that out I don't put that up just a
bunch of little things that were unfit
alright now the big thing for me as juju
juju catalyst movie catalyst cuz I
really want that catalyst and yo juju
have you tried you Julian PvP
little bit not many impulsed rifles can
like might go figures range I know I
love that thing but I have tried Ling
tried some bygones try to add you to the
range online that I play with that thing
is definitely good but I mean bad juju
in the right distance bro dude you just
I don't know what it is about that
archetype it's just very meta mid to
long range um it feels like a scout and
I'm just I'm really be stood with my the
one-on-one I'll see if I can now treat
you with my play on that emissary map so
I got my range oh yeah yes I'm no doubt
one right deal yes to Kingdom Ray's
right there but yes and I'm working on
our last things been working on I don't
know why it means working on blacksmith
it's gonna be a long way you like you're
gonna go flawless the raid I think I can
do it I think you do it like that's
that's a couple of the titles I've never
done man I mean I've got five four done
I got chronicler this week and then I've
got like one step left to do I just need
to go like finish crown sorrow for they
mm XIX but man looks like flawless rates
I just don't have a consistent rate
group to do it if you do man go for it
so that's the big piece like I need a
couple people the key is gonna be the
power run that's the key cuz that is
where everything could go haywire you
know I'm saying but the other two
encounters for the most part you know
once you got a confident team and at the
light level you know you should be
alright so yeah that's pretty much it
matches knocking stuff out getting
builds together and you know prep her
for 2.0 was like absolute change did you
did you get it bro oh no they got
Platinum's got one man that's some
stylish this thing feels like an anime
that's come to life as a game like this
thing bro it is amazing right now like
switch guys so much come on oh it's fire
emblem and then I got to demo for
dragons heroes like when I'm at work
well I'm going to go like I got so much
to play once which it's it's like it's
ridiculous it's like I don't even know
what to do
yeah it's like what do I play is I'm
just under
there's so many so many good things but
yeah astral chains out I've been wanting
that for a long time I'm a huge fan of
platinum and this game it's just unique
cool and quirky at the same time I like
it nice yeah song that came out got Lake
I think 90 on reviews like nines and a
couple places and yet control come out
get Nate fives and nines which is
another one I want to try like if I can
get done with a remnant and maybe
squeeze that in but then Borderlands is
coming that's on the 17th so you got
like two and a half weeks if you're
trying to squeeze some stuff in before
you know the big boy steps into the room
for a little while oh yeah oh yeah you
already know Borderlands is definitely
gonna be one of those for sure that
takes up a lot of space for many people
that's these servers are gonna be cool
there's this like two-week drop whatever
could they should be able do something
sneaky that week it's only so much there
they have a schedule out there so
they've been known though secret little
drop or something I wouldn't put it past
them you'll see I was like when it comes
out on the 17th you've got iron banner
you've got mayhem valor it's just all
the boost in the end I think mostly so
they're probably not gonna go too heavy
but yeah for me I've actually was I
finished up my comp grind so and I'm
waiting to pick I know it's stupid just
cuz I want to record it all together
I'm literally waiting the pickup because
I'm trying to get my bounties done for
crucible so because I want to get I'm
gonna get read Rick's broadsword hijinks
like this it's the damn five resets but
I'm finally I have those done so nice
those are all done so I'm gonna have
that mountaintop and revoke from checks
together just like Bam Bam Bam pick yeah
baby all gasp yeah you landed it up and
then I look down and I was like 88% of
medals on hush so I finished that Wow
cooling right more crucible grinding me
like you've been going hot crucible well
okay I'll be honest - shout out - I
think the guys name is dusk bumped into
him
plan on crucible and I was like and he
went off for like a 40 I was like oh I
was I was yeah so like you and him comp
and I was like and I think he was
working on some
else's butt yeah I was like um dude
you're really good he's like yeah 5500
player he was like yep make sense
jumping in a sidecar slash backpack and
rode that one cuz our glory level was
like 12 apart that wasn't like all the
way up together there was one point he
was at 20 98 and I was that like 20 90
because we had kind of going up and down
and we were like right there and then
finally we pushed over the top so yeah
the glory so I checked that box a
mountaintop provoker I had to solo grind
out the rest of provoker but got a
couple streaks and knocked that one out
comp is interesting but I like going on
no just like I enjoy comp if it's
control if it's survival which is kind
of what they're gonna have as a lot of
survival I think oh man when it's like
countdown it's just do not feel like
I've got it I haven't don't I'd suck at
that boat I'll just let say I'm which
you man I'm which I'm just I'm just not
a fan of it it's no fan of it just
mechanically oh no just a pacing of it
it just never really resonated with me
and the fact that you really just don't
even have to do the objective you just
kill the other four and that's almost
the better way to do it which is yeah
problem like was the way to do it don't
put it on there yeah so mmhmm yeah
knocked out all my comp trying to get
things done so destiny kind of put a
little happy bow on it by the end of
August so then September is gonna be
some light destiny obviously do random
things like knock out shatter throne or
something like that but overall kind of
try and try and actually give myself a
breather because I have been grinding
stuff so hard and Soulstice you know
there and a lot of people absolutely
take that refresher and you know palate
cleanser and then get back into it in
October so yeah that's a way to do it
it's a little downtown yeah but we're
only gonna get so much of a break
because we got to come back and do a
little bit next week because next year
begins we've got the Community Challenge
on Mars so they say with a bit of extra
time before shadow key begins we thought
it'd be a good idea in the community to
fight shape to get in fighting shape to
return to the moon so on September 3rd
for the full week they have community
objectives that were they're going to
want us to do
175,000 wave seven escalation protocol
bosses killed hey you got 300 million
hive on Mars that shouldn't be too hard
because there's a gazillion more higher
than bosses yes Mars nightfalls 150
thousand on Norris and then a hundred
thousand doves all oh wow
they're both going to be active next
week and then three hundred thousand
override frequencies that's the one that
I think is gonna be just annoying
because we all have to go out and be
like override frequency drive over here
like everybody just open one just do one
me ha ha ha put in your like put your
two cents in and just hopefully
everybody puts their two cents in you're
good but yeah you're gonna be Mars is
gonna be a popular planet and I don't
even know if it's in the flash point
rotation or not it might be but it I'm
sure is mm-hmm good questions that's a
lot of stuff - yeah I was like that's a
lot of stuff to do and then the other
piece is we got two rewards coming from
it one we've got that kind of Mars weird
emblem and then the other piece that may
or may not have some people excited
depending on if it's too little late to
the party so if the community this also
service opportunity to for you to
further impress empiric Alice if the
community reaches all the above goals
calles will unlock additional rewards
for successful Minotaur completions
learning when goals are met players will
be guaranteed to rewards when slotting
their rooms and opening the chest and an
additional Ward will be added each
Friday for the remainder of the season
so if you do next weeks you potentially
will have to and it'll be three four and
five possibly if it happens my question
is do you even care at this point do you
think I guess do better way to put it I
mean the rewards are good I think
measure is one thing they're asking for
so I think most would agree on that do
you think these rewards justify this
crazy community objective or would you
like to see more than an emblem in his
chests yeah I think there's just a
sneaky way to get it's just like
activating you don't get a little bit
more activity there but um you know I
mean what is this because we're at the
end of a season because the end of a
season so it's like you know am I gonna
get crazy about this no but um
is right now I think what it is the
problem is because it was how it was set
up in the beginning with menagerie
everybody was getting everything
everybody's kind of got everything they
want and then the but you know the
majority is a base just like these new
guys that really don't know the
mechanics so I don't see that much of an
engagement anymore so they were in a
tough spot they're in a tough spot man I
mean I understand them not wanting to go
crazy with the wars but they have to do
something so I think this is their way
of inching towards that there's me
mm-hmm
I mean I'm the same way it's like I I
don't like emblems the way they seem to
want to throw him out there all the time
yeah I'm glad you said that
I'm glad you say so like a really
popular award and even for like the
Destiny community like the artists or
movie of the week or they've got live
levanti's fashion think um and I'm like
I mean there's some that you'll wear
proudly and like never take him off I
know render managed to get in the like
the Bungie bounty when they were doing
that oh yeah The Guardian calm stream so
he actually just got in the right game
at one point and he's got that one he's
like I've never taken it off and that's
cool because some of those are like
ultra rare but a lot of them are just
kind of like do I really need like I
mean so it's like there's so many of
them I can I'm not I usually don't even
care to go pick like I'm which I'm glad
you said that because um shout out to a
guardian radio and a little brief I know
you know they say what it was was um he
was talking and he was just like he was
upset about how destiny currently D
values two ships almost like almost
everything is almost in him and like
back in the day you know as deep one
guys you know I'm saying like that ship
meant a lot like especially Val if you
run around with that whispers ship right
you know you put that work in you know
I'm saying so it's like he was saying
like you know he just wishes they go
back to that because because of stuff
you know the ship specifically you know
I'm saying in every verse that was your
trophy that was your bragging I wish
they would kind of go that route a
little bit more with these kind of
exactly do you like the emblem is like
yeah you never say someone's cool you
know I'm saying Prometheus land stuff
the walls but other than that it's like
I could really kill it's already got my
set ones that I like yeah I mean they
gave us some cool ones for just being
part of those and then you're like you
gonna give me a random Mars emblem for
just being there when the moon at Mars
activity happened I'm like my favorite
first off like the emblem itself alone
I'm like it's it's fine it's okay it's
not even that yeah it's not even that
popping like yeah I mean it's kind of
like the blurry it's like a video that's
like security footage that just like to
cook it or something it's I don't know I
guess just weird it's all fuzzy and I'm
just gonna techie you so I don't know
it's like I mean the event is cool and I
like the idea they're actually like are
gonna have us tracking I think the
tracking this out is gonna be on Twitter
they don't have a live game place to put
that would be cool if they did just like
if you hovered over it on the director
and it would like pop the information up
to see even it was just like information
as of you know the days reset it doesn't
have to be like live per se right just
to give us an idea but yeah Twitter's
gonna be something to watch for that one
for sure absolutely them so that's most
of what's coming mm-hmm I mean outside
of that we know iron banners going on
this week have you been touching iron
banner much I've not I will though I'm
gonna touch tomorrow and like I said
I've been stuck doing all this other
stuff but no like a lot of building
stuff without a weapon rolls little
menagerie weapon roll kind of things
then playing around like I said I was
telling before what he's an army and
that kind of thing um very close to
unlocking a lot of stuff I'm trying to
just monopolize that at one time so yeah
I'm gonna get in bandit oh I'm because I
what I need what you got I need that
swarm with a raven despite that was I
got so lucky like a hundred percent you
could do a hundred turns and I've seen
people do plenty and not get the things
so mine was a random bounty on my hunter
I was turning in bounties to finish my
solstice armor I was like screw it I
knew fifty pounds I'm just clicking on
these and check all that and I was like
I was warm when to go check it cuz of
course everything was full with the
postmaster and I was like wait a minute
that's uh I was like and then I got
filled prep was like what oh wow field
perhaps one of the Raven and I was just
like I'm done okay I'm done really I
don't anything so that was I mean but
that's just true luck that's all that
mm-hmm but I mean other than that you
could turn in 250 more packages and not
get anything because most of the time
you do but if you are gonna turn
packages in remember do it on a
character where you haven't done the arm
request because if you're doing the arm
request that's in a loophole - as
opposed to like have at least just steal
the weapons and don't throw the armor in
there as well mm-hmm but I mean for
September we've got update two point
five point two point two
we've got moments of triumph last week
in infamy boost finishing up another
iron banner and then mayhem comes back
the last week of September with the
Valor in infamy was just there boosting
everything there throwing it all at you
at this point which is a good thing I
think mostly because if you are working
on any of those trying to get as you
said delirium you're trying to get your
resets for red Drake's any of that type
of stuff they're giving you all the
boosts and mayhem will be in there and
all those things are coming you know one
other thing before we move on to Luke
stuff which is gonna be our big topic
for the day quality of life updates for
window go and mountain top we have the
official yes stuff so for those of you
guys going for Windigo grenade launcher
kills are with a hundred percent more
per objective death penalty no longer
exists for the final objective mmm
launcher multi kills grant 50% more
progress and completely playlist rakes
grants a significant amount of progress
towards the final objective huge so
they're really getting the and what kind
of get to this but yeah end of the
seasons and end of the year like here's
your push yeah mountaintop now this
thing got dropped hard or these
requirements are definitely in the realm
of doable now I mean you gotta get to
fabled but these are these are in the
realm of much much smaller so you got
the multi kills has been reduced from
200 to 75 Oh less than half and then the
three the calculator trajectory three
grenade launcher kills without dying
from 100 down to 25 that is significant
that's a quarter Wow
that's significant that is really
significant points earned in competitive
have been further increased relative to
other PvP modes roughly 1 times for
competitive
for iron banner three times four comp
mmm so iron banners going on right now
you could get more in there if you're
working on it and then comp is yeah the
big one yeah I mean they dropped over
half off the multi kills in a quarter of
the medals hope I mean we might be
seeing more of him out there that's yeah
we goes we go see a bunch of mountain
towns matter I mean look you know you
know I felt about that question you know
something had to be done
I'll be honest I didn't think it would
be hit that much you know saying so I'm
very curious you as the hardcore you as
the og paver of the way do you feel a
way about this honestly no okay I
probably should but I really don't
mostly because and Luke actually
mentions this at one point cuz he talked
about his grind for Windigo same thing I
went through four mountaintop I learned
to use breech-loading he launched yes
yeah and it was the skill that it taught
me with that whip and so now when I get
mountaintop yeah it's gonna be a
different trajectory of it but I know
how they function I'm not just gonna
pull fighting lying out or just always
use play of the game and then go get a
breach led and be like how do i function
this thing how I know absolutely
absolutely yeah he made a great great
point I was thinking about you when he
made that comment cause literally that's
what you said and and how you got even
more effective with with the breach
loaders yeah so I mean parent fighting
lion it was with militias but you pear
man well mountaintop still when you run
against it though that thing hurts it'll
hit you hard yeah definitely hits you
hard so it's I don't know it's one of
those I think those are still enough
where you'll kind of get the idea I mean
even if they were cut even if it was say
both of them or 50%
there's a hundred multi kills and fifty
of the other ones the multi kills the
one that was actually the slowest so the
fact that that came down a little more
than half but then say if the calculator
trajectory was like 50 and the other was
75 that might balance out I think um I
just hope it's like I think it'll still
be enough time for people to learn them
but I will say by the time I got to 200
I was like I definitely felt a whole lot
better just like oh I happen to be a 25%
well they're gonna have calculator
trajectory done by that point
yeah yeah it's gonna come a little
quicker which is good for many people
who want to grind it out cuz it was it
wasn't insane grind but the learning
curve is is definitely a thing so dad's
got a question for you reference the
amount out uh how often be used the
mountaintop since getting it okay so
it's this is what I was saying earlier
everything's still sitting at shacks so
I can pick it all up in just a little
clip because I'm gonna go like Bam Bam
Bam and be like right acquire it I just
want to record a stupid little gift
that's all oh yo you got patience for
hold notes for getting it and not having
that excitement to touch it immunity I
give you credit but just let the chill
in the in in Bank man yes I go up and
I've state escape on that one have to
hit a skate on the road and then I'm
like I think I'm eight bounties I picked
up a couple yesterday that I need to
work on so I'm like eight bounties away
from red drugs as well so if I can go
one two three my bakery is gonna be full
so good but yeah so that was just a
little tweak I found I saw the official
stuff come out it was on the Destin
forums and then it fell out on Twitter
and places so that wasn't not in the
update surprisingly so I'm not sure why
that wasn't in there but mmm we made it
through the initial stuff guys now we're
gonna hit our deep dive destiny twos new
third year mmm
so before we even get into all the
minutia which there's a lot
what is your for one I didn't even see
this coming yeah this was a sneak attack
yeah I'm just going along with all of a
sudden like I literally I didn't even
see it anywhere else it's one of those
times I was like oh what's on the bungee
page is like that's new I was like on a
random Thursday I'm like that's not that
well that's is that last week's part
three no well crap what is that and then
I dive in and I'm scroll through I'm
like this is long yeah just initial like
thirty thousand view like what are your
give me the gladiator the thumb up oh
just a little nick view off because it's
like yeah are you gonna start it here
you gonna starting out starting here
yeah you guys start it here we gonna
start here okay so right darling okay
it's here it's here I'm in the middle of
in the middle area there are things that
we're gonna get into that are really
promising that I really understand and I
think are needed to happen and there are
things that I'm not gonna say are bad
but you know you got that I like let me
see what you're doing I've that I like
what are you really doing here and um
you know IIIi his outfield I will say
this again I'm going to generalize
because I know we're gonna get into
specifics but this is gonna sound a
little messed up but I kind of feel that
the other are directors cuts now in this
beautiful transparency right this
beautiful part of you is like this low
Petrosian was too slow big that we go
chuckle you know I don't think anything
here's as bad to me as you think it is
so we'll see where you at I'm not a
hundred percent but I'm like mostly
positive I mean that like seventy five
eighty percent range cuz there's nothing
I can completely understand that will
we'll get into the point when um I'll
tell you it where I have my lower bro
I'm sure we're gonna hear an earful
other means requested catch last week so
I don't know what the deep joke is there
but man gonna do some pain coming oh
yeah pains coming I'm coming for nice
they must bend the knee but could we
would continue on this too so he gave us
a general overview of what we have kind
of so far we got obviously rise of iron
size expansion no shadow keep the moon's
coming everything's vague when he talks
about it of course we have armor 2.0 and
overhauls system
now the one thing we haven't touched on
too much yet and they haven't gone deep
on besides what we've seen is the
evolution of difficulty systems which I
am excited about because we have a
little more there's the only Twitter I
tweeted one thing about this you see my
one tweet of like my six words of text
about this entire thing yes I did I did
so that's like I was going through that
was like there we go
so difficulty levels hopefully crossing
giant fingers here hold on giant fingers
is gonna matter for multiple reasons and
then they talk about new light and cross
save and you know playing with all your
friends so we know that enough and we're
like director's cut part three left this
giant elephant in the room
hey there's this thing about temporary
content how the hell is that gonna work
because we talked about that with was
that with no yeah we did talk about it
with Tassie yeah yes three was that was
two three was crucible and it wasn't to
him we had tascioni way was to so yeah
and I remember Tassie having concerns
with certain things about that yeah and
we'll get down to the artifact and this
is why I went through this yesterday
just like trying to figure out what I
was gonna put videos out I put one out
this morning but it was like I was like
oh let me just run through this and like
ended up being 30 minutes and I wasn't
done was like I've got to say less I
know I'm long-winded anybody who knows
me I'm sorry but no I for sure it was
like I was like deep diving on the
artifact and what this could mean this
that the other I'm like crap I still
gotta talk about the ranks so yeah it's
a it's gonna be three videos I was like
Jesus cuss yeah well how you were doing
a bit like is with me with the writing I
putting some game that met and I'm like
this was supposed to be a short
assessment I'm like I'm almost rewriting
a table right now there's other things I
want to talk about I'm like I can't be
writing rewriting the table like it's so
much to unpack like this was a lot yeah
so let's get it man let's get to event
lots of fun stuff to talk about so they
have a couple things that they want to
do they want to make sure when people
come into destiny as blueberries with
new light which is gonna be a big deal
they want to give the tower a place to
call home they want to make sure they're
told want to stay in the game
so there
on different ways to help all levels of
players and they have the impossible
task they have the hardcore streamers
who play thousands of hours in one year
you have your people who get to log in
and only play for like two hours on the
weekend and somehow they're trying to
make a game for everybody and that's
next to impossible it's impossible
you're not gonna please all the
audiences but I will say from what I'm
seeing here I think they're trying to
give options and places and long term
grinds to go for that actually work on
that but before we even get what we're
gonna get to first thing is this
evolving world of destiny that's what
that's what my video is out about this
morning nice so I'm glad you talked
about this oh this is the first one is
this your is this your pain point I
wonder or is it later no no this is not
my main point because this kind of ties
into the very end of the story
so in somatic sense I'm gonna put these
two together
I gotcha sassy so basically what they
say is currently and this is like the
metaphor I used in my video I'm sorry if
it's terrible but mmm
take like okay so you got a table and
you're like okay here's des New Year one
okay I'm gonna put my library book of
des New Year one on that one okay so
I've got my expansion of Osiris set that
on top in the Mormont set that on top
the entangled Shore set that on top then
you've got dreamy city set that on top
and then just a are start adding to
these stack of books and this things are
getting eventually just huge mm-hmm
there's a point for what and there's two
reasons I think they're doing this one
they will never acknowledge probably
officially on a table but if you just do
the math on it it's the base consoles
you have a 500 gigabyte hard drive and
yes they do on ps4 is gonna be a hundred
and sixty gigs
fax and the way their whole system works
with download a patch copy the whole
thing you need like twice the room or
whatever so so what however that works
if you have a 500 gigabyte console which
is really like 460 of usable space then
you go 160 and then if it copies over or
even just what's sitting there they
can't keep making the game forever big
exactly now people on PC are like hey I
have a five terabyte hard drive I don't
care yeah and I have all the space you
can't you can't they can't build for
that they have a hundred million people
or
stupidly insane number on ps4 mm-hmm
they probably have what is the number
like 40 60 however many X boxes as well
there's a hundred fifty plus PC as well
they have to still develop for the
lowest common denominator
exactly you got to go to the bases right
you gotta go with the biggest bases okay
and you also chance segment the the
population by doing one thing for a set
certain set and not the other so yeah I
agree so that's one piece that is not in
here but is definitely one they are
working on addressing eternally as best
as they can
mm-hmm now the other thing which is
where I got really excited because
that's just like that's technology and
that's how it works the other way is
where they decide how what the seasons
are gonna work in the future and I think
the best word if I can find where he
used the word at least mmm-hmm he wants
a world that has a narrative momentum
yes and I was like I like the way he
phrased that because currently and even
Daddo said it on the Vidocq interviews
mm-hm he's like there's a lot of just
balls in the air right now because if
you just go through our campaign we had
Dominus Gaul his whole red war campaign
and the Calais is just sitting out there
and his plane of Union ship mmm then we
had cursed level Cyrus your boy sitting
out there in the infinite forest with
his thumb up his butt not doing anything
well he's out there in infinite forest
land while we're facing nightmares
coming up man do powerful warlords get
your paradise for future we that we are
unaware of right we're about to face the
vex without him dude we don't know just
give me the trials rebirth whoo you know
I got a whole deal fine oh so then we
got war mines campaign we're like we got
to hear war mines horse then he's like
deuces yeah then we got the aldryn piece
on tangled shore that led into the
dreaming city but oh yeah woke up five
we have the dreaming city the forever
loop which I don't know if our level
nine nine nine is actually gonna do
anything but they'd be so amazing if it
does but the dreaming cities just stuck
in purgatory and I feel sorry for every
one of those people really Brobee thinks
so much like I
[Music]
you're like taking things I said mmm
verbatim that I wrote my take on so why
were on a podcast I think yeah we've
done this enough
but then you've also got ADA she came in
we don't know much history behind her
she's just chilling in the tower
you've got the drifter who has the
emissary whole connection and stuff
going on you've got more Assad out
fighting who knows what that we don't
know about there's like 18 different
stories in the air right now and we
don't have a conclusion to one of them
faz dado brought this up beautifully oh
he during the shadow keep reveal he
literally said it was like all these
unanswered but I bet you the word he
used was threat right like yeah just all
these threats are just all like this
right now it's just an MS yeah they're
they're cool individual threads but it's
like can we get some continuity and what
we're about to talk about was just oh it
was beautiful it was beautiful
yeah and one of the rare moments we've
actually had continuity and that's why
it had I mean that's why taking Kings
expansion was a big deal because we
built on a previous expansion we built
on crota Oryx his son you pissed him off
he came in just wipes out half of it
like that whole area so when things
build in this game they're awesome
mm-hm as opposed to like rise of iron
was cool but that story was so just like
here's all of destiny and here's this
like a little box on the side where you
do this old stuff yeah yeah so like
those are odd segments and they are
trying to get away from that mm-hmm so I
will say what the future or what he said
this past year could have been like and
then I'm gonna let you cannibal and then
I'm gonna let you read through what we
got coming because I've been talking a
lot mmm
so I've looked through it enough I don't
even have to look okay and talk about it
so I want everybody to picture in their
mind that this past season pass so we
finished up the forsaken campaign we're
working on the Dreaming city it's late
November this is how they would like
these to go in the future by the way so
picture this as being a hopeful
possibility but December first little
note shows up in your postmaster saying
a be in the tower December 4th 10:15
yeah
right what's going on everybody's in the
tower the tower instances take forever
to load because everybody's going in but
everybody's sitting in there waiting
like be in the tower waiting no and
we're all sitting here waiting
crazy crazy bananas ship pulls up 801
trans mats off of it she just casually
walks through the tower and down into
where the black armory is now opens the
door we go in there she unpacked her
stuff and she sends us off on missions
we start unlocking the forges and that's
how the season begins she comes in she
unlocks it cool as we do more things
throughout the season we unlocked the
forges the look of the black armory in
the tower changes we start to have more
stuff in there we start to have more
weapons show and we have more you know
things displayed behind her I'm also
doing this we'll get a random cinematic
somewhere like her in The Drifter have
this little spat they're talking to each
other and the end of the cinematic you
see The Drifter like zoom in and kind of
ice some schematics be like in his head
he's like pan that weapon looks awesome
how do i skeeve it so yeah he's thinking
and then you know working through a
two-season
maybe we're in the last month and you
know we finally got everything unlocked
on the drifters lake
hey you dredge ins over there just the
people who have earned dredgen title
first come here start working on this
stuff for me I was like I got some tasks
for you we got to build up some supplies
we got some stuff to do and then like as
we get towards the end of the season the
last two weeks you start notice the
black armory whole area where ADA's
starts emptying out you see like boxes
and then maybe you load in the next week
and some of that stuff is Patton is out
of there it's getting really empty and
then that last day that thing is empty
completely empty she walks out and kind
of forces you out and then she shuts the
door behind her she gets back on her
ship and she leaves oh and then you
noticed that you couldn't find the
schematics like the last couple of weeks
where the hell were they where the hell
were they and finally you stopped by
Banshee and he's by the way by the way
Aida luckily the schematics I'm gonna
have these in my weekly rotation so
they're gonna come through and drifters
already got you working on his stuff and
we're in the midst of his as we go
mm-hmm so oh yeah by the way
with the hypothetical other version
looped through so much shade at dado I
about fell out of my chair because I was
like oh hey and it's like yeah in an
alternate universe where dado got first
in the red nose like I felt bad I was
like 24:02 forever but damn Wow
but yeah so take that image of the story
aided coming in having the cinematic
oval having the tower look change
working on the forges those are her
activities then she has so we're like
working on the forges working on the
forges then she gets up and leaves we
don't go to the forges anymore mmm they
are no longer an activity but now it
would the drifter stuff now I know not
everybody loved the drifter but just
imagine it went from a toe to callus for
example but either way that is what they
would like to get to right so what I
want you to do now it says the world of
taste this thing changes every season
like let us know what we're gonna expect
mostly I'm talking about paragraph two
and then that to you audience all yours
yes a portal to the black garden that
was opened as a part of jacket quest has
awoken the vex and they are now pouring
out across the surface of the Moon
working with I Cora players will the
parentheses do some stuff go somewhere
fight some things and solve a problem
aka redacted by the end of the season
the portals will close the world state
will change and the seasonal activity
connected to it will go away yet
something remains this would just be in
time for adapted to kick off the
startups the season of season 9 for the
first time we get the name season of
dawn Oh interesting
are you doing I have nowhere to go as no
I don't buy zero
I actually didn't even translate I don't
even know it everyone who plays dusty
will now be able to see how the world is
different and changing during season the
holes with the season pass will be able
to play a seasonal match main activity
within the black garden for that extra
levels we hear this
to the old and new paths and you'll pass
access but the goal is that everyone
will be involved in how the world
changes and at the end of season your
collective actions will have called to
world state to change and the seasonal
activity connected to those events will
go away now this is my paragraph right
here doing this allows us to evolve the
world but potentially Namie narrative
lis but potentially physically as well
it's not it is not possible to keep
dusty frozen in place to allow all
activities to live forever while also
change the world in meaningful ways this
strategy lets our team be more agile and
innovative we believe that destiny will
grow even better when the world state
can change and that the best destiny
stories are the ones were yeah you had
to be here when you know that so then he
goes on he talks about armed events an
activity in the world evolving weapons
critical weapons weapons critical to the
meta will not be locked in each season
for new players or for players who
missed that season Legendary's and
exotics you need to stay competitive
will be our eternal in the future
although not always immediately after
the season ends we'll be talking more
about that later this is one way with
the new seasonal model we expect our
plans to evolve across the seasons to
meet the needs of the destiny community
and then he goes on about you know
whatever your perfect Guardian is yeah
you gotta play this was a lot to unpack
so I'm gonna go in a reverse order here
from kind of the bottom up yeah let's go
yeah I'm gonna leap actually all of
those guys as usual so there's not a lot
of games that have been alive for an
extended period of time where they
actually want to change the world
something won't last long enough where
it's gonna matter World of Warcraft is
the prime example and this is where some
of these game directors come from this
is dumb history in gaming and I would do
the same thing classic is back out there
now you started in wild classic you have
two giant ass continents sorry language
my bad good that's me I gotta bleep
myself but you have two giant continents
and then when they had two expansions
you had Cataclysm which added a separate
world that you'd go through the portal
for you had Rachel latch on the Lich
King which was the northern frozen area
up top and they keep tacking stuff on
mmm
same place we're in a destiny
and then what happened I Cataclysm just
absolutely came through and just
destroyed like the two main continents
you had a basically a fire Valley go
straight down the middle of some zones
different activities were no longer
there zones looked differently hmm
so you had physical world changes to
like your main continents that you were
used to
gameplay change there was a different
evasion these things were different
places all the stuff went on because
they were able to completely revamp the
entire world now Lily those contents
were a hell of a lot bigger than decima
but lower resolution stuff like that but
that's still a hell of a lot of work
that they did but they completely
changed the landscape of your base game
and that's what they talked about
specifically when they say they allows
us to evolve the world narrative Li
which we just got done talking about the
story but also physically if you ever
have a point where what if something
happens on earth and you know the ship
unnecessary
gets attacked and then some piece of it
falls into it now there's a crater of
part of the nessus itting in the
European dead zone mmm so they have ways
to change up the planets the landscapes
and it gives them a reason to do so so I
mean that type of stuff is really really
exciting yeah I mean that's mine that's
my first piece now you pick something I
mean we got you you own it you own it
because at the end of the day this is
what excites me you know I'm saying and
this was I've always felt was the floor
initially with the first season content
with like literally reading what were
you hearing you read what he said about
how black armory could have been yes
right
remember what might my main main issues
would who is this chick yeah why is she
just in a tower how nobody ain't noticed
you know was there like like it was just
it was just so convoluted because we all
agree we felt black armory the content
was solid and for the most part and it
was a lot to do then maybe grind it to
grind it but it was a lot to do the
thing always came down to narrative Lee
it just didn't connect there was a
disconnect we didn't feel could you
imagine if she flew
and for the tower transmat it's a
community event everybody's walking to
see where she is she actually goes to
that section of the tower opens it up
you're like okay now I'm connected right
so this is what this is though and I
think this whole theory of seasons
bleeding into other seasons right so
you're setting up this nice narrative
continuity that that they sorely need
soil you about the jumper I can see when
you have it because I've been talking
yeah it's like they sorely need that
because that really it makes it gives
you that connection and then um yeah I
love this whole thing about you know
world states and and things you know
evolving and then we'll get to the other
part that I know a lot of people are
worried about which is no events ending
right and things you know going away and
at first you know excuse me like Tassie
we were a little nervous like I don't
know you know we still got to see how
it's implemented and um the main thing
though I think is just like it has to be
that way in my opinion it has to be that
way because it's like you said he and
like Luke said at some point the demon
city cannot stay cursed forever like we
can't go to do it every day it's like
you don't say and it is other things
going on you know I'm saying so again
the key that the issue I've been I've
really I really wrote this entire
sentence right here when I was are the
key for them is going to be they're
gonna have a tough old tough spot
they're gonna have as if if it's a
beloved event like a menagerie you know
I'm saying if it's a really love thing
you know and now narrative Lee you gotta
move on I I feel that in some way
they've got to bring an iteration of it
for it you know I think that has to
happen for the rest of the game in a
community to feel satisfied I think you
just if they snatch away I mean just
it's not gonna apply to like raised or
anything like that I don't think so
well I think at some point you know if
they take away stuff they have to have a
similar substitute that people
okay this is like version 2.00 Benari
you know I'm saying it's something like
that so that people don't get too upset
but it has to get done physically it has
to get done and I'm sad because like you
said the constraints of our physical
systems and consoles do Lois comments
and aunt nominating can't keep adding it
you're not gonna have anything left on
the map there's gonna be there's gonna
be too much and then the second thing is
obviously from a storyline perspective I
think is doing I'm willing to trust them
on this for those who are nervous and
we'll entrusted me but that that was
your what was your feel I was your
overall feeling when you read this part
you made it yeah you're real feeling is
your overall feeling it is I'm
speechless over here I know honestly
this is exciting because I mean he said
it in one of I forget which part the
50th time you've gone to the dreaming
city is not the same as those first
couple special times you see it mm-hmm
and as I said in my video we make our
own funds and we're referring it but I
was like it was I think it was mostly
brought to a head when everybody was
trying to figure out in six hours how do
we grind for crown of sorrow mmm what is
all this list of stuff we have to do go
back to the Dreaming city where like
again I leave the mission do the you
know first piece of the chatter throne
mmm then you go do your weekly missions
then you go to your daily missions all
of this crap we have to do but why am I
still going back to the Dreaming city
for crown of sorrow mm-hmm I mean that's
that's a big question of story I mean
flashpoints rotating through that's fine
I hope they do more with that know that
they could they could do a lot of things
with flashpoints to make those cooler so
hopefully at some point they do and I've
got to defend my boy broken just cut you
one second that's what killed those
Cyrus to like girl most I was got killed
by the lack of narrative continuity like
it made no sense okay he's here no
mercury didn't help the face face and
even one of my big one of the biggest I
feel offenses that was egregious is also
the way don't get me wrong not
disrespecting eater of worlds as a raid
but continuity was why did we have to go
back to the Leviathan right it they
needed to explain that whole bit and it
just disconnected like I said he was
never given this type of treatment now
if Luke Smith reimagined black armory
if Osiris had that treatment bro is no
doubt in my mind he does in that it
would be well-received Belov people
would go crazy you know I'm saying
that's still shadowy man come back but
at the end of the day this is what we
talking about they have to do but could
continue listen where was I I cut you
sorry you just talk about like you know
no continuity pain stuff with that yeah
so I mean dreaming city has to get
resolved hopefully at some point I feel
sorry for them if it doesn't because
they're just stuck in purgatory yeah but
just the idea of an evolving of an
evolution but it's also gonna keep
things fresh it's gonna help keep us
going - hey do you have to go back to
the dream you see no you don't because
you can't yeah well if I kind of like
the dreaming city well it's fine and
this actually when we get to the
artifact is a discussion more of what
the temporary content is because they
say those part the part of the season
pass is the seasonal match-made activity
within the black garden mm-hm
has this you know the sweet gear yes sir
that's the seasonal match-made activity
that will be going away so my question
goes into what's up
the nightmare hunt mods mmm-hmm because
it's a seasonal artifact right but the
big thing here at least when you look at
all of this is the fact that they are
setting the precedent up front they're
letting us know with the artifact in the
builds that we're gonna get they're
letting us know this content we're gonna
get is not lasting forever and I don't
know how the developers feel about that
hey I made this awesome play space and
you're gonna play it for ten weeks so
neck then it goes back into the thing we
talked about last week or the week
before
what what level is this content how
high-quality is this content as it is
going to be temporary right nor is a
good question there's a good question I
think on they've got they've got to be
they gonna have to put their hats on as
far as juggling that level of engagement
and enjoyment for something that will go
I will say this I mean because we know
Bungie they tend to be on the number
side of things you know I'm saying and
analytically they track and stuff I
think it's gonna start off initially
with the lowest performing content like
the lowest perform I don't know if it's
for dive no whatever I mean right like
reckoning you know saying maybe
reckoning I well then again who knows
what I began from everything you those
are both staying through year three
right
but I think what's in the game currently
is gonna be there I think it's what we
get in their future is what's gonna at
least evolve maybe like next September
they'll be like hey by the way this
craps leaving or something yeah but and
that's fine it just it's gonna be
curious to see what's the determining
factor is it gonna be all just because
it's narrative right is it gonna be
oh we're looking at our player
population and yeah you know what
they're not really doing forges anymore
this is 750 drop and they can't go for
[Laughter]
more baby gets far more in exam but yeah
I think it's gonna be a combination of
them that's just my guess narrative are
loops things that have to happen you
know they have to conclude we talked
about you know Jimmy City stuff curse
stuff and then also you know other
little things that's going on to so yeah
I mean the fact that the world is gonna
change is cool the fact that that's
where they want to go is cool and also
the big elephant room that everybody's
gonna be scared about what about these
cool weapons you'll be able to get them
and you'll be able to get them later but
you will be able to get them eventually
if you keep playing this right so how do
you feel about this six months implied
thing that I've even hear from Luke
witness other people max of six months
yeah I mean it so let's say
hypothetically you know Tran thi
thinking you see it's gonna be hard for
you cuz you don't a cruise which I think
of what what okay
I got one for you now oh this is it man
zero-hour right let's just see
everything true which no peace included
in content though right would you
consider it but everybody got to do it
okay so you don't consider you don't
consider like chatot throwing that kind
of stuff you said it I just like a bonus
chatter turns a dungeon that's its own
animal the seasonal content I think the
only the content itself that would leave
is gonna be mostly what comes from the
vex activity so it's really what would
be the forges I mean take hammerhead
take blast furnace those are your
seasonal comparison okay in my land and
those are damn good guns so then if you
go back to where hey you have a three
months to earn those she has her
bounties that you can choose to work on
say you don't get your role and then and
then maybe there's one of those a
banshee every week it's definitely gonna
be a longer grind to get them after the
season when they're not totally you
should have you could probably be able
to get a gun mm-hmm but sure god rule is
definitely gonna be harder to grind
after please I guess I still confuse you
probably right right with the way they
probably handle it just like that
I guess I am confused with something
like shattered throne because again when
I think sad it's wrong
I think ascendant realm I think kind
again I'm not wish I wish we had by for
Milan right now I'm not saying to really
understand Lorelei's shatter throat
right but I always connect it with that
whole dream and city curse bit and maybe
I'm off I'm saying so I'm just saying
like in in theory if list as I said yeah
okay so that's different I was going
more unlike the seasonal basis if at
some point they do like rap dreaming
Sidious rotation right that's what I'm
going with you because I know that it
throws your heart right and let's just
say and we know what's a wish ender
comes from that right so that now goes
right because this curse is over they're
moving on oldring's back or more he's
doing you know and then something else
is happening right yep I question to you
is how will you feel that you can't do
shattered throne anymore or is it one of
situations where I did
everything I had to do it was hot while
it lacked like he said it would you
should have been there when it was how
are you that is you're more of that
I mean honestly at this point even as
its up this week I haven't just run back
into it like I've done it enough I've
spent enough time fighting that damn
ogre to know how he works and figure out
like I've done solar backpack baby wait
wait for the call it's like but I've
gone through it enough and figured out
the fight and challenged myself it's
like that's why it's hard for me to go
back and play something like Dark Souls
multiple times without like I would like
to go black and back and play
blood-borne at some point cuz the thing
has been long enough that would be
fairly fresh but there's still the point
where you kind of take the the initial
off from any of those pieces and that's
why going better the Dreaming city fifty
times or going better shredder thrown 10
times it's still something we don't
always need to do now it's cool like
you'll be able to do wish endure and
give some bigger stuff like dungeons
sometime so I mean having dreaming city
be here for two years is good probably
gonna be plenty or maybe if they wrap it
up say in season 10 who knows they're
like okay hey we're going back to the
Dreaming city on season 10 older and
woke his butt up now he and Petra her
talkin there's this little place we go
visit him you guys have just knocked out
Dylan karu she's cool then at that point
you've had a month a year and a half if
you didn't play it in that time fair
enough maybe it's I mean yeah and that's
cuz I guess I'm of a different mindset
of some and you might be the same as me
well but I mean most games I've played
as you get a new expansion as you get a
new piece of content as you move forward
in the game you don't keep dragging this
like like Santa sized backpack of crap
behind you and I know my vault is not a
bad a good example of that mm-hmm but
the idea is you're not always like I
don't want to use Gjallarhorn for ten
years and they've said that I did not
want it to come in and I still don't
want it to come in mm-hmm so I don't I
always I want the game to evolve and see
new things and see fresh stuff so the
more definitely that's all I'm with that
no no no I I was just curious because
like I said I know how loved that is for
you so I was just curious you know to
hear that you know for the new dungeon
keeps me occupied there well there you
go there you go I think I think I guess
it's the tough
but I think it's the right cool I think
it's the call that has to happen I think
um because then it also lets me write
like when you conclude it feels more
real it feels like this is truly a
living world where there is a beginning
and a conclusion to events right cuz I
know for me personally there's one
reason I want it to end is Odin I want
to know you know what's gonna happen
when it wears his mindset what's going
on with that like it brings destiny back
to that narrative cool story thing that
you know we know they got this
tremendous Lord I think they can tap in
with that with that so yeah I'm with you
it'll be tough for certain things I'm
not gonna lie but like you said a year
or two you know if you come on you ain't
rock out at this point then you know
it's on you yeah and then maybe at that
point where she endures just in the
xotic loophole yes dad that was my next
point you still okay so yeah I mean
that's where I would see a lot of that
stuff headed at some point hmm some of
the plaintiffs are still gonna be there
but you have dreaming city that isn't
primed for something like this whether
it's a season this year whether
something happens with older and Mara in
year four who knows but at some point
that place needs to have something
happen otherwise it's just the the
elephant address in the corner that's
just like sucks yeah and it sucks to be
that element itself this all leads into
the other piece of temporary content
well two temporary things one our
seasonal artifact oh here you go
he's been waiting for this one he's been
waiting I'm broken down he looked at
every mods back and forth here we go
here we go this is all you right we did
it yeah so what they said is they wanted
to make sure they give us more
transparency more predictability they're
still gonna be orangey in there though
they want to give us some direct paths
for things which they're working on and
they're still gonna have orangey drops
in the games and roles and stats that's
older exciting line for me all of those
things they want to get in there so
they're introducing two new things two
seasons on top of what you normally get
don't be like hey well I'm getting this
stuff I'm not getting my normal
activities and this with the season
you're still gonna get your narrative
generally a better one than before
you're still gonna get your activities
just like for just something is gonna be
part of that season so that type of
stuff is still gonna be there they're
just giving you more in case we don't
have enough today artifact is the new
thing mm-hmm
so the artifact is gonna be free for
every single player new light old new
shadow keep doesn't matter everyone gets
their own impact mm-hmm now the artifact
is gonna be a seasonal artifact as we
know mm-hmm couple things about it
you're gonna have mods that you unlock
as you level up the artifact and then
you're also going to have a power boost
level as you get experience and levels
throughout the season now it's a
seasonal account-wide
as they continue to learn because that's
a huge thing power boost and they said
they're both excited and a little
terrified yeah where players manage to
get their power levels to so now are
right now we know 960 is the the armor
cap from pinnacle activities mm-hmm how
high do you think your your glads your
streamers your people who play Nate a
day are gonna get that artifact from
doing their bounties and 6,000,000
crucible matches and where do you think
those things are gonna end up it's gonna
get crazy I'll be buttons it's all
dependent on how post max level light is
I'm saying like how that whole XP you
know transference happens if it still
remains at normal level
to you reaching you know that cap I
could see the hardcore getting crazy
with it so now it just comes down to how
do you balance that hardcore or do you
just leave it as status quo and let them
you know run crazy with all this power
so it'll be interesting you know I am of
the mindset when it's like I think this
is still it's an experimental phase but
I still think it's a good thing to
reward the hardcore community by just
playing
they have this option with these
artifacts to keep leveling and making
crazy builds that didn't get crazy with
where you add it because you are on this
list of the heart of the hardcore the
hardest core brah really wanna list a
seat of miles you putting in network
let's go so like what excited about
multiple things one mmm-hmm when you
jump on which kind of ties into seasonal
ranks later
you're able to make progress towards
something even if it's just like hey I
want to do a couple game at matches I
want to do a few crystal matches just to
burn off some steam whatever even though
crucibles Tilt I'm sweaty but still you
just want to go shoot some stuff well it
gives you Nick it's one of multiple
reasons to literally just go shoot some
stuff hey I'm gonna go knock out the
flash point there's a reason I don't
have a cared about the flash point in a
while you know there's always a reason
to go do whatever you want
mm-hmm so that's big for this and the
season ranks which we'll get to but also
for me again I have more questions than
answers what's the question no I'll just
kind of go through my whole spiel yeah I
was giddy all right so there's a couple
things the temporary nature of the
artifacts lets them do the artifacts not
being here forever lets them play swing
a little bit farther into the power
curve for our Guardians make us have
some more powerful builds prime example
in the heavy brick finisher mm-hmm okay
so say you get somebody who gets like
rate mods a raid armor they have like
stupid level in like they have like a
hundred intellect so they're like tears
hit on an electric charge so the Super's
coming back fast okay you got your super
all the time alright you put that heavy
finisher on you give us heavy mo all the
time that's your role you're given us
but it takes half the super but if
they're out there like picking up orbs
and doing other things and giving heavy
ammo and they've got master weapons that
heaviest popping constantly mmm now that
sounds really cool cuz everybody's like
hey heavy having a controllable way to
get it but if we get to a point where
you literally are going through a raid
run you're like in a boss room and
there's like 50 heavy bricks on the
background nobody can pick up there
maybe a point where it's almost and this
is what a good thing now they get to
experiment now and they set the
precedent on day one this lasts for
three months or in this one ten weeks
right so whether this is broken Opie or
not you know it's not gonna last then
you're like coolest have you finished
your build is awesome sweet I get to
enjoy it for a while I know at some
point it's gonna go away
it's like it may suck that it's going
away maybe the next season's gonna be
cool too who knows and they said if some
mobs are really cool they may bring them
back in other ways yeah yeah so it's a
temporary way for them to try stuff
swing a little harder into the PvE type
things that is what a lot of people want
like crucible its own thing PvP come on
I want my crazy crazy guns and it's a
way for them to push that envelope
farther but also have the reference for
them or as they state here I'll just
read his last line in one of these
paragraphs we wanted to figure out if we
could have a system allows players to
create build altering powers yet not
need to commit indefinitely to whatever
they have made and make sure it lives on
forever they want to give you new builds
but they don't want to have that new
build be in their combat system forever
out they want to give their self variety
but they also want to they want to have
a little more fun with some of these
things they want to make sure you can
feel a little bit of power in different
ways or having different purposes and
builds which is for me really exciting
so I mean that's so what I don't know if
I talked about this last week before but
I've said it and my stuff the second one
on the fifth column it's a little group
void grenade one the possible build that
you can do with that for especially like
a Titan for example or hunters the same
way I'm going to Titan word of dawn
weapons of light you only get one buff
on your character where there's well
radiance weapons of light doesn't matter
you get that right right the enemy also
gets one debuff right so you take a
Titan guess what he wants to be a
support build so he's gonna spec
intellect and discipline doesn't give a
damn about anything else
discipline is for the void grenades that
new mod allows your void grenades to
weaken the enemy now we don't know how
much but even if it's a debuff on an
enemy it's still weaker he also has is
it super up more frequently because he
spent intellect and he has weapon
word have done with weapons of light so
now he's liked you you have one
character in potentially say a raid team
of six one character doing the debuff
and the buff for your entire party well
five other people are doing their damage
right
nobody has to run well this person is
not over here doing teather everybody
can spec for Golden Gun Celestials and
just go absolute bananas well one person
handles the support setup no Philip dad
filler has potential in my mind now
maybe I'm crazy but like that type of
build is something really cool but say
what if this the grenade thing they put
in there what if it weakens the enemy
too much or they figure out people find
ways to like I'm gonna throw 60 grenades
no it's not a solar grenade so Sun
bracers wouldn't do anything there cuz I
already thought about that right but you
have possibility of people making
grenades where energy is coming back
people have ashes to assets or all those
other mods they can finally smash
together and it's going to potentially
give you something broken yeah but oh
and here's the Noah's gonna say any
here's the thing it's not gonna stay
there forever so even if it is and maybe
you guys are smoking this right boss
well guess what and guess what next
season
all gone right so you cannot depend on
that stuff and it lets them it lets them
play and I like that I would just want
to say that did this to me this to me is
a form of sandbox playing that you know
we've been on them let's be honest right
we've been on them about you know how
long it takes and stuff like that
and I think this is a way that they get
to communicate to us and we give
communicate back with them through
in-game play with these artifacts and we
are going to find things that are
definitely going to be crazy we are
gonna find builds you don't saying yeah
really gonna be synergistic and um you
know and they're all the words you know
say thank you thank you but um yeah man
so it's like we're gonna find those and
what's gonna happen is you know they're
gonna analyze it they'll take the data
and then I'll see it's a fresh start
next season kind of thing so ultimately
I like it
than me I like it the only question I
have he is just not even about the bills
to me the bills is that's what comes
with the territory of you know crucible
scientist guys PvE you know that people
are going to find things the question I
have is just now with that power right
like with that extra artifact power how
is that handled when those people go
into a raid or maybe you know content or
you know how's that handling like I'm
banner my let's just say so what an
assumption has to be anything
competitive it doesn't count it's only
gonna go off gear score and that would
that that has to be they have to be
explicitly clear that's it because you
know again one thing we realize game you
know deci plays we'll find something
once they find they go and boots that's
that's really it what I mean is that is
that someone like losing sleep over no
but I think this artifact thing could be
really cool you can be so the other
question this raises is the fact that
it's temporary if you look in the second
column on the artifact every one of
those mods is related to Nightmare hunts
yes now maybe they're related to vex as
well I don't know but they're for sure
related to the nightmare hunts because
it said it on the damn map top view are
barrier middle to or overload the bottom
one I still don't know but it's the mods
that are for basically the D buffs or
challenges we're gonna face and higher
difficulties in the nightmare hunts
mm-hmm and this was the big question
everybody thought that Nightmare hunts
were gonna be your temporary activity
but if they say the seasonal activity
which is that little Terkel is bubble in
the bottom left corner of the Moon right
that we saw that's gonna be your match
made vex activity that will be going
away so two questions one oh is every
artifact gonna have a second column of
mods and they're just gonna steer you to
different weapons as we go through the
year cuz shadow keep is its own thing
you buy a shadow keep that stuff doesn't
go away doesn't anyway I think the other
side is
if the all those weapons right now and
maybe they just want to steer us the
playstyles maybe in the nightmare hunts
maybe in the nightmare hunts there like
auto rifles submachine guns and cannons
and bows cool next season
pulse rifle scout rifles fusions and
snipers next season breech loader
grenade lot like they're gonna they're
gonna steer the lake if you want to be
optimal in these settings the idea is
you're probably gonna want to use what
works with these mods so if I'm going in
with a pulse rifle yet auto rifles get
these mods and I can't use them I'm
shooting myself in the foot right right
so that was my question is like is every
artifact going to have shadow keep mods
on it and at what point do the shadow
keep nightmare hunts end or is shadow
keep gonna have the nightmare hunts we
go down eras wakes or crap up we go in
we fight these nightmares just as we
push the VEX back in their portal do we
like into the source of the nightmares
and isn't that how they progressed it
yeah I'm leaning towards that I think
it's gonna be very very content specific
like giving you buffs and stuff towards
activities that's based in that season
and things that nature
um I completely agree that they are
going to be pushing their meta-narrative
similar call it like which is let's be
honest there's times us has a destiny
community we get a little arrogant we
get stuck in our ways with best time to
kill most effective you know weapons to
mill bosses yadda yadda yadda or close
in vain there you go you know so I think
this is their way to say hey this stuff
that you've been not playing it's not
bad it's it's actually very good if you
actually give it a shot you know say it
again
for each loaded you know grenade
launchers that you learn quite well you
know Xanadu there's a level of
effectiveness so I think they are going
to be pushing certain meta-narratives
with this too
kind of nudge us in that direction to
give things a shot and um yeah I
completely I can completely see that
that's what I'm going what are you what
are you thinking I mean that's a big
thing because what do we not you I mean
hand cans around here we know they have
70,000 hand cannons a game that's not
news but when it comes to auto rifles
and submachine guns especially in a PvE
setting besides recluse but with these
mobs recluse is gonna be a beast mm-hmm
they're trying to say hey auto rifles
hopefully for one they buff them because
they do need them I'll be honest yeah
but also it's saying this build that you
have for these nightmare hunts if they
do stay around next season you got to
find a new new set of weapons with so if
the nightmare hunts don't go away and
they stay around for a while they're
gonna be like hey these nightmare hunts
are still here they're with powerful
gear but all that crap you were using
before not gonna work
yep so it's gonna kind of change up and
also as this is like a the season
artifact you got to get to that next
tier it may take a little while to get
there but maybe day one you can't quite
get to the nightmare hunt mods you want
so you can't just go crack on like the
highest difficulty on day one they're
gonna make the the seasons last a little
bit longer as well yes you are it that's
very this is literally gay sign trickery
but in a cool way in a cool it's like
they're not like forcing us but it I hey
if you want these cool perks he's extra
buff hey maybe you need to dust off that
lederhosen rifle that she ain't been
doing you know is like that's what I see
how are you doing how you doing your zip
free bring it out you know take it on a
date you've got bread right now -
crooked fangs they are all that stuff
they don't know one don't say that you
really been using and see what's up you
know get them edged transits ready yeah
it's gonna be some stuff that we're
gonna be like really all right listen to
have like I want them to ever do like am
like in Diablo did the secret cow level
I need I need them to make in a boss and
like a mechanical seva boss made of edge
transits
oh my God look like we're walking robot
thing made of edge transoms legs that
are hilarious I would lose my mind
hello an amazing easter egg for those
who were there during like oh my god
mm-hmm so yeah I mean you've got you've
got very specific mods that go for an
activity but they're separate from the
season in a way yeah so that's why I
wonder if the artifact is always gonna
just steer what you're gonna use in
there but the other thing you've also
got this middle tier and they're like
hey do you want fast reload for cheap
hand enhanced hand cannon reloader
costing one energy as opposed to six is
massive this that's best yeah I mean you
got submachine guns at one that one may
not be as much bows as one
maybe you just everything feels like
hush nail fusion rifles and then auto
rifles but all of enhance hand cannon
reload speed being one take your boy
style but guess what next season but
none of those are gonna be on there yeah
thanks agree so you've got the ability
for them to for one with the heavy stuff
maybe there's the void grenade build
maybe it's the heavy finishers to be
like hey this is cool okay this is what
we want the meta to be we've got some
cool weapons coming out let's steer you
to those that hand cannon thing with the
hand cannon reloader
and the new exotic let's come in oh yeah
an IP snipe yeah that that's gonna be
powerful that's gonna and that might be
a way to be like oh there's also bows
listed in here there's a bow as well
guess what you're gonna be using those
exotics but you have a nice reason to
use them as well in that Bowl would
Eris's real name was he on I don't know
I saw the name I have no reference to
who that is I remember hearing her say
it oh maybe it's one of her original arm
ray teams that got went slaughter down
there and crota I remember her it was
one mission on where you beat the
mission and she's naming the names of
the crew I believe that she was waiting
and I remember her saying that name
that's why my death name sounds so
familiar that Ariana's foul
you don't saying that I believe that's
part of the
what you call it but um there ma'am I'm
excited to see how these things that
they're gonna reward us would also
correlate with what is actually buffed
mod Wow I mean that's you know available
mod wise to to accelerate so yeah so I
think all of this generally is a good
thing
yeah the artifact power bonus level is
gonna be kind of cool what's this lets
them experiment with crazy stuff a
little more as opposed so it's gonna be
in those little balanced bugs maybe not
and they can honestly say hey this thing
I mean finishers those are only PvE and
then the grenade mods weaken an enemy
it's probably not gonna do that much in
crucible it might be but if you should
kill her damn with a grenade they're
gonna die fast anyway so yeah most of
those aren't gonna be things that change
the way you play PvP but they will
change the way you play PvE which is I
think where they are trying to also
steer differences which is a good thing
yeah I feel like I had more to say about
that but we've all but I mean it's gonna
be a temporary thing they're gonna go at
the end of season we'll get something
new and we'll see what's next season of
the dawn could have who knows we'll just
have a little ray of sunshine for
artifact but the this I guess this has
to be where your big question mark is
mm-hmm
the final piece of seasonal progression
that they're adding on top of everything
else case we don't have enough to do in
this crazy game mm-hmm they're adding
something called seasonal ranks aka yes
what do you want to call this thing
battle pass there you go let's go for it
night before yesterday battle pass so
I'm gonna read through a couple pieces
here on the top and then we can talk
about you know what it's gonna have so
you've got basically they just say they
wanted you to have predictable paths the
artifact is one if you play up level
you're gonna earn these cool mods that
are gonna do different things in the
game and you know exactly how to get
them take an orangy out of some things
well they take an orangy out of some
other things as well of just playing but
they also know when Guardians play as we
said before some people do it for a
living
do it eight hours a day
some people play two or three some
people play two days two hours a week
mm-hmm some people don't have time to
like lock in for a raid group they only
can pop on for here's a oh here's a
crystal bulb match so I gotta go take
care of here's the crucible match I
gotta go you know change the kid
whatever it is not everybody can make
the commitments for all levels of
content so they're trying to give the
people who are on D especially I think
more the lower end but also give the
people on the high end something another
piece of progress that they can try and
burn through mm-hmm
and try and give you at least a linear
path in an actual expectation visually
of what do I get when I do this
right so we've got on hundred levels of
this thing now I am what I would call
out of touch when it comes to battle
passes whether apex whether it be for
tonight in this game I'm gonna say
motors you because I rely I'm familiar
with them I know of them but because I
am NOT a battle royal guy like I'm not
setting foot in those games to be
regularly to break to break down the
intricacies of like how this compares to
there's you know I'm saying the all I
remember is you know do plugging in and
built what the goals I think they share
that but um yeah this is interesting to
see in destiny and um this was the one
that remember I told you I was like oh I
know it was like I was waiting so yeah
before we get into all the nitty-gritty
or I want to bring up late what is your
reservation and then we'll kind of
explain how things work but like what is
it just spill the beans what's up all
right this is where I'm at with this
it's like I get the dilemma they have
I'm really trying to be empathetic right
they have this tough balancing act where
it's us the hardcore the guys who drive
it the guys if we leave their finish
right then you gotta talk about growth
right you gotta talk about little Timmy
you gotta talk about you know Suzy and
whatever that works a full-time job
you gotta work you know you've got all
shout to market yeah I did
I caught dados giant I caught
I'll talk about that that was a good one
um the thing about it is it's a tough
balancing act a hardcore anything so we
started off with the the artifact right
part of that is gonna we got new light
and no artifact that's how look at what
the casual stuff so new light boom you
come in you're not left behind yay I'm
with this Bungie that's that's cool I'm
for that right then you have the
artifact thing right okay hey maybe I'm
getting unlucky with orangey maybe I'm
getting whatever whatever but I can
still get my just by leveling up XP and
towards the quest and I'm still getting
things I'm feeling good about myself
even though I'm not on Pyro's reteam
sweaty a you know sit or whatever
whatever I cool this one not saying it's
bad I have to see it but I must admit II
I feel uneasy only reason why I feel
uneasy is okay you got the top path and
you got to get that the free tier and
you got premium tier right so just by
playing you'll get this you get that
you'll get this you know legendary thing
you know whatever glamorous suits
whatever okay but if you look look at
the path and then look at the premium
path and under number rank 25 I know
okay so what ISO right 25 got a little
uneasy a little knees and I said I knew
this is one that was gonna freak
everybody out and I'm really good at all
it could very well be just an exotic
Ingram he's just gonna be very well be
but we have to admit exotic engrams that
helps towards power when it helps
towards place that helps to wave you get
if that exotic is something good you got
an advantage a little bit you know me if
it's a good exotic that someone else or
it could be another pair of a on souls
and you just call your Louisville man
but I would you yes you're right it
could very well be but for God I'm
thinking of a guy like myself who it
took me a long time to get Gio I was
every forsaken exotic would not drop
my way I look at this and I'm like okay
let's be real since forsaken those drop
rates have been nerfed to oblivion like
it takes a while to get what you want so
again this is a minor thing but it's one
of those things it's like even whenever
verse was first introduced we were kind
of like gotta watch you gotta see what
you're doing
are you go all you're trying to sneak in
monetization and play to win and
thankfully they didn't right so I'm
gonna give them the benefit of the doubt
but I do it is my main thing through the
exotic scroll you know I'm anything easy
I don't know how I feel about weeks the
last two to four weeks of the season
that you've been playing and I could
just come in here with my checkbook and
say okay let me get all this let me buy
rake 100 I don't know how I feel about
that okay why
it just feels you've been you've been
the hardcore you've been grinding you
okay so they've been playing and this is
just the same I this goes back to the
mentality of some people like oh you're
gonna make year one free to play how
long have I been experiencing the
content right I'm gonna play this for
eight weeks straight and then in the
last two weeks if you want to spend more
money to catch up to where I'm at more
power to you okay no no that's like
that's mailing if you want to spend
money on that pass and you haven't had
to one it gives an opportunity for some
of the whales or the people who have the
money to help live and bungee and help
support this game absolutely know what
this is we don't this is this is that
like act like we don't know what's going
on Oh what so here's like it doesn't
bother me at all one bit I feel you III
all I'm saying is for me it feels weird
it feels it's not egregious
that's what I wrote is not egregious but
and it's not power level II all the way
but I do feel that you know I'm coming
in a person could come in and just you
know kind of buy they just gotta be
careful they they they gotta be careful
or what's available in this thing too
this is how Trojan horses start so just
keep it my things like keep it cosmetic
keep it keep it materially and I'm
saying like you see how I got the
legendary stuff the glam rock okay cool
when I say exotics know about that one
and that's what that's part of what Dad
Oh me and dad are on the same page just
dados whole thing is he's like look man
like I don't he's in the same boat I am
like it's not like oh my god they're
doing some awful this is evil look at
this this is pay2win it's not that I'm
never gonna say that it's not that we're
not there but when I again they have to
toe the line I have to be careful and
I'm saying because I see people I've
seen the comments I've seen right and
I've seen people on my arm discord and
they'll say yo I don't know how I feel
about that you know I'm saying and that
cuz what it is is on battle passes for
other games a little bit more egregious
with stuff like that and maybe people
are worried about that coming in to
destiny but that's it I mean as an
independent studio I get it you gotta
have monetization sources you you gotta
you know you're not Big Daddy Big Daddy
Activision ain't it you know I mean you
got to get the break coming up feel it
but they gotta be careful that's all I'm
saying you gotta be we could get
slippery slope if they get crazy I don't
think they will I'm giving a benefited
out but it was just got to be careful
okay so I want to answer one for
dramatic he's saying it doesn't feel
destiny you can buy cool stuff but not
power level you're not buying power
level your seasonal rank does not affect
your power level of your artifact if you
didn't play
you're still your power level still
never gonna be that high does not affect
your level one iota correct that is just
your literal seasonal rank through this
like progression of the ten pages of
battle path stuff
I'm sorry I couldn't finish I'm sorry
can say the other pieces you do see one
exotic in there I bet there might be
three in a hundred levels mm-hmm okay so
here's the thing so take take your
player who wants to pay for it take the
player who's played all season take
somebody like glad I'm gonna live in
this game for like months grinding all
his stuff out getting that perfect
season he's probably gonna be level 100
completely done he's also gotten seven
more in who knows he could dock that
crap out in the first week if he's
bananas nut we don't know how fast
that's gonna go
not that quack but say he doesn't two
weeks he has three exotic drops in there
he also experiences sir possible faded
in Graham exotics that come through and
anything else that comes from there and
his playtime of other drops that he's
gonna get mm-hmm he is far beyond
whatever somebody who can pay money and
catch those last three and try and catch
up that person who hey I had a contract
in another country for two months I came
back I've got three weeks left of this
season there's some cool stuff in here
there's some armor sets I want to get
the vex whoa and they have really cool
ornaments to him let me work on that and
then you go through and okay you got two
weeks well let me let me get this thing
I just got done doing my contract made
some extra money let me drop it on this
season pass let me burn through see what
I can cause they said it's a boost I
don't think you're just actually like I
don't know if you buy the levels or not
I'll be curious how that works if it's
like if you play and you're getting
experience like crazy fast or what as
you progress through then in those last
couple of weeks you've got the end of
the season getting a push of more people
potentially playing and then also those
people they've missed out on all the
world drops all the other things haven't
been around for eight weeks of zarur
they've missed out on enough stuff that
I don't feel that part I was like
they've missed out on enough stuff that
there's no way that I see in exotic
every 10 levels I don't see that now and
if there's like and if that's like eight
twenty five fifty seventy-five
woohoo I get random exotics every so
often and most of the time they don't
matter if it's truly just an exotic
Engram it could still easily not matter
mm-hmm alright so that's me I want to
talk and also read no it's like that's
me and that's one of the read what
people are saying in chat too this is
great discussion and again I think it
comes down to literally what is actually
going to be I need the full extent of
everything that's gonna be included in
the season right right so you know
you're making you're making a good point
I mean like it could be very much were
like a if it's exotics you haven't
played you've been out of town that mom
I mean you know it's funny this actually
benefits a person like me knows it I
travel all the way up doing convention
Abdullah's shows you don't
I'll go to hardcore periods of Destiny
and I have periods where I cannot play
the game because I'm doing stuff right
so yeah this this literally benefits me
right you know again because of the RNG
nature of destiny and if again if it's
strictly like we see in legendary shards
capes and suits who cares that's nothing
you know but if this gets into exotics
or exotic weapons and stuff like that
you know it's a little teeter E but
again like you said it's not affecting
the power level it's not you know you're
not getting put it this way longer than
ain't no guarantee like I want C
outbreak perfected they will never do
that and I assume they won't that's all
we we as a community though I just would
say as a community I would hope that
they are smart enough to know that if
they they cannot play with this it's the
same way like everyone's they cannot try
to get sneaky they cannot try to XP
filter remember that was the thing we
got we got a call to spay this but
listen I love my bungee but they got
caught with the pants down with the XP
tuning and now Luke got in front of it
and said no no no we're not doing this
but again we got a C it's one of those
things I have to see them prove it that
they are to be trusted
with this level of this is the new wave
like this is the new way this is what
all these guys are doing um what you
call it all you know for tonight all a
popular game this is the new
monetization wave and I'm not mad at
Bungie for attempting to get in it just
do it honorably that's all we say
because I'm telling you that Bungie if
you get if we find you know reticle me
lady you know you know someone gonna
have the algorithm I battle pass and
then I did before you know you know I
guys get so let's just see that's I'm
willing to give it a benefit yeah I'm
far beyond benefit doubt I'm just not
worried about it and that's just me and
maybe it's just like ignorance or
trusting in Bungie too much or just
basically seeing what they describe as
not being something that's gonna break
the game they even describes the
armor sets in here we know armor sets
are gonna be a thing but something I
also talked about later mm-hmm it's
gonna be your base level stuff mm-hmm
if you want the higher level stats you
gotta go get it in the game you're gonna
get base level it's probably just like
we're gonna login and get our [ __ ] our
solstice armor that's like base stat
level you're not gonna get high stuff
it's gonna get you started but it's not
gonna be pinnacle level stuff they're
not gonna give that away so what is in
the season pass let's break this thing
down because we know the season is gonna
last 12 weeks or 10 probably was gonna
be 12 if it came out on the 17th but now
it's 10 because they pushed it back so
apparently they're still gonna keep to
their cadence mm-hmm the season pass
includes the following for one season of
a dying does come with shadow keep so if
you buy a shadow keep not the digital
deluxe or anything else just the 35
bucks you get season of a dying to
period somehow also and I'm not sure how
or why you would want to do this you
could technically buy season of undying
by itself it is truly ala carte so you
can buy the seasons as you choose which
is they are very clear that is 100% ala
carte I don't know of anybody who would
do it that way but you can so that being
said what comes with season of undying
outside of shadow keep of course for
most of us we're gonna go season pass
owners get access to a new seasonal
activity the vex offensive we know that
there are four weapons that can come
from there there are additional weekly
bounties and weekly challenges for
powerful gear just like any of their
activity go to the forges it's the same
thing go to the reckoning it's the same
thing certain stuff is gonna be in the
seasonal activity that's just how that
works season pass owners do get a weapon
quest and they've done this for the
previous annual past this isn't new
quest for the exact bull leviathans
breath mmm-hmm that is the giant heavy
chains beast but mm sees an artifact
says use bows guess I might we'll see
how it works yeah we gonna have to do a
new exotic hand cannon is available for
both the premium track you get it just
by having the season pass now that I
have an issue with I'll get back to in a
second oh we have an issue
I never said things were perfect on what
everything was all good no I don't care
about the mana I don't care about the
whole battle path stuff I don't think
they're gonna ruin that this is how
they're handling it exotic that's a
different animal but at level 35 you can
get it for free somebody with new light
can still learn that hand cannon that's
cool so they go through and level 30
late they level up they're doing strikes
they're doing patrols they're leveling
up they get to level 35 in their season
rank and they get this hit pan cannon as
well you know what that's kind of cool
give somebody incentive who has a free
game something to go for that's pretty
awesome
three seasonal legendary armor sets now
this is where they talk about my
favorite quote in the entire damn thing
so basic complete so collect a complete
set during the first 25 free ranks so
you'll get a complete set for each class
during the first ranks on the premium
track you'll get all three sets at Rank
1 so if you buy the season pass you're
basically they're giving you some stuff
up front they get the hand cam and you
get a couple armor sets cool it's just
the big thing about armor which I hope
people really start to understand it's
not gonna mean that much you're going
for stat rules and you're going for how
you look but outside of those the
functionality of mods and all that stuff
I mean that's all separate so you're
going for how you look and hopefully ad
since that role but the free stuff they
give you it's not gonna be amazing stat
rule right that is true it's almost like
the old ever vert armory where was like
super craft kind of almost an crap mod
similar it's like what you get for free
is not going to be the top and they
truly stake on the premium track you'll
get all three of these sets and these
are for the VEX Offensive X offensive
activity if you want versions with
higher stat tiers and I exploded in my
head when I read that hahaha you'll need
to play the VEX offensive to earn them
me finally to add some additional
premium Trek Awards literally all
cosmetics ornaments a weapon ornament
two more weapon ornaments a finisher a
team ownership all cosmetics facts so if
you have that many cosmetics in there
you've got armor sets you've got glimmer
legendary shards well it looks like a
couple of extra bounties harmless
right dust whoa harmless I'm with you
bro I'm with you oh I just gotta cut you
for a second no no all I'm saying is
this the story of the Trojan horse the
story again I'm not saying they're evil
I'm not just like the leap to even
reference that as a trap I'm harsh man
that is like this is how things start
that's all I say so it's verse 2 and
look where we're at
you're right but then what again but we
not going to get about the XP thing we
can't I'm not gonna let these my people
he's my favorite studio but we cannot
act like that didn't happen it was a
throttling this happened who was
responsible if that do get fired
they even addressed the XP by the way
they got caught if it wasn't for red it
says stop that with my XP there in front
of this they're cool it's up to us as a
community to say yo we feel you just
keep it fair keep it clean keep it cool
and we're good to go
you know I'm saying but trust me eat
everything you're saying is accurate
this is harmless
this is materials this is this is not
nothing to be scared of that's I get you
I just got my eye open okay I feel like
I've got like people shaking their
walking sticks at each other and chat
right now what is happening in check
let's go to let's get to our just funny
so I got a couple things about this one
and this is what makes me hope there are
more exotics in there we know about
things we know about these two they've
been showing up I'm off and trailers and
I guess they're gonna tell us how we get
them but the fact that literally ranked
one of the annual past we get that
exotic and cannon hmm take some of the
whoo out of getting an exotic hand
cannon like exotic weapons should mean
something and now like you bought the
season pass here you go yeah there you
go
like I mean it's cool to get a new gun
and start the season off with like a
nice little here you go but exotics
don't feel like they have that weight
that they should anymore and it's kind
of one of those things that it just
that one is kind of a glaring thing at
me right there and I'm not a huge fan of
that yeah III mean I I mean I'm in the
middle I'm like I'm not thrilled about
it I guess the reason why I'm not going
crazy yet is more so than I'm confident
they're gonna have so many other exotic
sources to do other things that will
probably forget about this it's just
that as we're reading this now it feels
like this is one of the sole things I'm
saying yeah so I'm not gonna get crazy
about it yeah but I trust me I'm with
you in a sense that I don't necessarily
know how I feel about you know just Iraq
at least rank 10 I mean what if you want
to game in here you go ladies like I
straight paid for that exotic it's like
a little bit of work would have been
good there but mmm guess I can't win
them all so that's like bad I do kind of
have a bit of an issue I mean they're
gonna give you the armor sets which she
can look how vexy you want I mean you're
part of the season pass you're gonna
look how you want to but again it's a
bass deer it's that deer and this is
where I got happy so let's go if you
want versions with higher stat tears
let's get this was my random speculation
last night when I was just word vomiting
into my microphone when you look at the
nightmare hunt activity previously and
said powerful gear Tier one and I
wondered what the hell on earth that
meant right I was like all right what
does it mean is that like it's gonna get
you from like 750 to 850
is it what is it like a prime Ingram
versus a you know legendary that might
give you one verse a prime giving you
six is this gonna work on the tornado
scale like is Tier one the low stuff and
if you see a tier five like holy hell
yeah I don't know but also in my head
you sit there and I was going back
through some of the clips of the armor
2.0 and you look at the helm and you're
like okay his helm has 56 base stats
okay maybe that's Tier one somewhere in
the 50s okay maybe tier two 60s tier
three 70s tier three 80s tier four like
how high can you climb with those tiers
and somewhere towards the top and this
is what I had asked for previously when
you went TAS he was on I was like I'm
hoping there are variations of Lake
raids are gonna hopefully drop higher
stat distribution points gotta be and
this is pretty much as confirmation like
if you'd like the free armor you get
that's going to be your base level stats
like that head has fifty stats randomly
thrown on there it's probably gonna be a
set value anyway right then you go in
and do the VEX offensive on ultra hard
you get something instead of having
fifty stats like thrown across the six
stats that we have you have 80 points
thrown across the six stats and that's
where like and I think this excites me
in multiple ways one you actually can
really for one like see improvement as
you get higher gear from a tip more
difficult activities and to it does the
one thing that we've had an issue with
lately rewarding difficult activities
let's go
that seems to be the theme about shadow
keep which I'm liking I keep seeming to
hear that narrative with different
things he's saying so that that's all I
want
you know I'm saying because they he
knows the follies of vanilla d2 you know
I'm saying that was these dozer Achilles
heels not rewarding the powerful stuff
the way that mean the harder actor
clinical activities the way they should
be so yeah that those should be in there
yeah I'm saying I think I'm confident
that that is you know the route that
they're going so that's that was for me
exactly what I was hoping for in the
stat roles I was like alright if every
head is 56s this is gonna be boring okay
this one has like 87 like I just got a
huge upgrade and that's gonna be
exciting is gonna make that that dead
drop you know to be able to play okay oh
yeah this you know that's what you want
you don't want this stuff to become
redundant you don't want this stuff to
become all another tier tier 5 or what
I'm saying like it start to roll your
eyes and stuff that's where Luke gets
exciting again that's what we want well
that's also like you have the stat tiers
and then you go run that hard content
and then you're gonna want to go run it
again why because you may have not got
the role that you want on that armor you
may have like int discipline and damn it
I need a melee and resilience middle
because I'm gonna go be up punching
stuff for whatever is right maybe not
everything smashes and shadow keep you
knows
as far as a chaise that's what you want
you want that level the same thing what
we have weapons we've always wanted
moment I think we're getting close to it
man I think this is definitely the right
direction I'm with all of this right
yeah so that for me is huge huge huge
stuff for sure the other thing they
talked about and we kind of briefly
touched on it it's 10 weeks when you get
to the end last two to four weeks and
this is where they're just gonna see how
the season goes beards like imaginary
beard twirling people who listen to this
on audio by the way Todd needles over
there electorial your bias but there's
no us older Jud we've been around the
block we just like I said we just kind
of I hope I'm not young dude not you're
at far behind you
let me flex my old car all right les you
stay young right now just don't break
something if you flex too hard you know
it's just what is the we got a watch
one thing that I like what they are
saying is that um if they're implying
that this is a fluid situation based on
community response and how its received
so I like the data yeah they're gonna
know I like that you know I'm saying
it's not hard and fast it's it's y'all
we're gonna we around week to to week
for around you know that kind of thing
and then we'll see and then we'll kind
of play around with it based on what you
got say I like that part you know I'm
saying so let's just see I got a again
it I could be making a big cry about
nothing and like you said II this could
literally be legendary shards BS stuff
that doesn't affect anything you know
I'm saying and allows a guy hasn't to
say hey I can get some rewards and stuff
like that but the only skeptical part of
me is if they're doing a battle pass
right you have to make for the this is
the reason why people like us sometimes
he's got you look at the monetization
model you look at you know fortnight
like that the reality is let's be real
they're a business they want people to
jump into this battle but if it's up to
bungee right you put a gun to the head
and there's no guys around and you say
yo what do you want out is you want the
most money right so if you want the most
money then you have to make this thing
attractive right you have to make this
thing a minute oh you know I'm saying
this that you know and that's all we're
concern we just want to see how
attractive are you gonna make it is it
like something cool could be like mama
how they did the glows from these
soulless the chrome right though the
chrome is in okay cool cosmetic you
ain't affected nothing you want to look
cool boom
but again I know it's just a random
exotic to you but it's exotic man drop
rates ain't you know saying so if I can
just you know pull out the ATM and just
be like you're not gonna be able to do
that till the end anyway mmm see you
gotta wait you gotta wait eight weeks
before that's even on the table seven
eight like you go hey I've been at this
season for like seven eight months hey
you want this stuff your friend over
here who's not currently playing the
game and they want to pick up the season
be like you know there's actually some
cool stuff in here if you spend like ten
extra bucks you can kind of catch up to
me
mmm all right cool I'll see you in here
come on catch up but guess what their
power levels not gonna catch up yeah
they got a couple extra exotic drops
maybe they get chances at some of the
newer things but they're not gonna get
all of it the way orange egos we know
that man it's a way for them to it gives
again it gives flexibility and I don't
think they're gonna step too far
as you said we gotta watch and see when
everybody logs in everybody's gonna
click on seasons click through all 10
pages and see you know what's there
here's your season pass stuff that you
can earn that's gonna be the first thing
that pops probably nothing else how's it
gonna be go to the director click the
seasons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10
screenshots both of them here's
everything yet okay there's like three
exotics hey there's ten that's a lot
we'll see don't know honestly I really
don't we got it we got to see it but
I think we were we in agreement only
we've definitely agreed and then when it
comes to the past they're not trying to
kill us they're like did bunchy just
raise the EXP needed a rank for some
ridiculous levels so players have to buy
rinks at the end of the season the
answer to that question is no in big
giant bold letters for example in our
internal team test playing strikes in a
fairly relaxed manner 18 minutes for
strike that's slowed by the way because
you can do them in about 10 you can do
it on you they be a very conservative
with a full stack of bounteous so you
get your 5 bounties that's it out that's
a rank in an hour
yes that's not that hard if you play for
a few hours you do bounties you do
things if they wait all the activities
right like if a raid is Worth's a decent
chunk of experience as long as all of
that stuff's right seems like they're
trying but they also said if they get
like halfway through the season people
are at like rank 30 well we messed up
and they have the ability to be on the
fly and adjust that so they're gonna
have the outliers of streamers up here
then they're gonna have like the casual
hardcore somewhere in here then there's
like you and me slightly above then
there's the people who play on the
weekends then there's like the kid whose
parents say you can play on Saturday for
two hours and that's it in this spectrum
is all of those people and they're gonna
try and put it somewhere in that range
so not every low person is gonna get
there the high people are probably gonna
finish it early and the average people
probably will finish it in the season is
their goal
it sounds like whether they nail it we
will have no idea until we start playing
it but the average person hopefully
should be okay on this front in case
there's not enough to talk about we also
have new light you now if you are gonna
play destiny to for free man you got
hooked up yo they getting hooked hey I
was like I expect all this I'm like yo
they are getting very nice borderline
red carpet treatment could pretty much
do a lot of things a lot of things yeah
take it I've been talking and I'm you
sayin much yeah tenshun old you know oh
no that's C two players are coming in
with light and it basically is gonna be
all in on shadow keeps you
then we'll have access to the following
so for zero dollars you're getting quit
to patrol the moon destination so you
got actually gonna go get to go the
opening mission of shadow keep Wow
didn't think that was happening to Lou
strikes normally strikes would be
omitted crucible updates that I expected
to returning pvp maps from the d1 arrow
littles court in Twilight gap I'm gonna
say that is also new because I believe
in the past they wouldn't get new maps
they'd be kana on old stuff on the point
where everybody has like all the stuff
at this point so yeah okay LM
elimination and crucible labs that's
Alma - yep that's cool ARMA 2.0 cool I
of the gate Lord seasonal artifacts when
they get the artifact you beardless
shoes they're getting the finishes - new
pinnacle weapons one for gambit one for
crucible do you think is gonna be one of
Vanguard doesn't sound like it no sonic
all right free seasonal rank rewards
which include the new exotic weapon
Ariana's Val Green legendary armor sets
one per class two legendary weapons best
of year two bright engrams and glimmer
and upgrade modules so yeah legendary
armor I said weapons come from the free
seasonal ranks are a little sample
platter
I like sample fighters for the season
pass if you want to find the best stats
for the role for the armor you'll need
to play the seasonal activity and get
the traps but players who just wanna
collect all the armor can earn the base
version from the free track I see you
pumping your fist see you probably face
this little like that way you about that
so yeah Ariane is Valda direct on our
seasonal track also drops on the free
track but if you get it but you get it
earlier if you have this e-pass they've
also added a lot of rewards in the free
track that a nice quality of life
rewards for players like upgrade modules
which are free infused again now this
sounds wholesome this sounds I could
bring that home to mom yeah I could
bring that home to mom and everything is
okay see like okay his purse is not
deceptive not you again just follow
through stick keep it here and we should
be okay should be okay
you know I'm saying so I'm okay I'm okay
so where you happen if you haven't if
you somehow haven't played destiny took
a break from it played the first season
had the weapons system burn you a little
bit you the way you get to try this for
free is great now new light players are
probably if they had played before they
are gonna go play with they played again
mmm but for people who are like yeah
destiny really okay it's free how what
do I get
breathe really you can play all the
strikes all of them now I don't know if
they're gonna be doing night falls or
not but probably mmm-hmm they can check
out elimination be like well this is
something they're working on that's cool
hmm all the crucible maps gambit and
gambit prime both are in there because
they said that in a previous interview
when we talked to Pino I thought it was
just one yeah and then like you're just
getting them both yeah so they get to
see both sides of that they get the gate
Lord they get their power level boost if
they want to work on that so they can
still work on leveling up they get the
finishers which is part of it and then
on top of that like hey well I'm a free
person what do I grind for how about any
of the pinnacle weapons that you want to
go for from your basic vendors if you
want to go grind out recluse you want to
get ready for PvE and this is still a
free grind you can do that a lot and I'm
gonna tell you right now besides cross
save this is going to be tremendous
I know people tons of people on my
Twitter followers that are like yo hate
destiny what oh well you started haters
from work you know always like saying
sly remarks you know I'm saying all
you're playing that game again that game
whatever whatever
oh I uninstalled destiny I'm never going
back to I have at least ten people who
have saw this new lighthouse or shadow
keep up so cross say but specifically
new light that is like yo I am in with
you on day one showing me the pictures
of them installing it you know like this
is a huge deal
the population increase is gonna be
crazy and then it's like that is a smart
business right get him in the door
you're giving them still a lot of things
to access a lot of stuff to do
that you give them that sample platter
first mister the shadow key no Nick a
GoSee coach Adam go go about a buffet go
see you like that you like that but
here's the rest of that you know people
go a cop there's gonna be people a yo
eleven way too much fun I how much is
right there I you know what his dirty
let me get the season and you know
people go and do it this is how they
gonna get people in and I think my my
god I'm not we talked about this with
Tassie we don't think it's gonna be in
every season thing that they do this
right what arms o dog silences the
wolves no no I have a weird reflection
behind me you can see yeah see oh yeah
you get the light coming through but uh
that's that new light shining through on
the third day the lightning the third
day the light shined and the new light
Guardians walked into the tower for the
first time Jays their eyes upon Shaq's
in Decorah Cevallos over there in the
corner and he's gonna stay there until
he gets us act together
I was so Cyrus is light shining through
the ojou-sama
yeah this is it is going to be
tremendous and people are going to eat
this up they're gonna want to stay in
that ecosystem they're gonna be having
fun
it is a big deal this literally throw
engagement numbers through the roof this
is why it's little more than one final
fight listen this this is why they
weren't scared this is why initially
they didn't budge and I know they say in
delaying it whatever but what you got
cross save and you got do light man you
talk about a shot now on to your player
base tremendous tremendous that's a lot
of stuff
and we forgettin Alucard
could you imagine let's say it mimics
how this past season annual pass
structure what right even though we know
it's fall right not gonna be three well
before you get shadow keeping it once I
got three more yes four separate yep yes
so um yeah man I mean yeah I know
vagabond uh-huh um but the whole thing
is it's like could you imagine you like
y'all I heard about drifter I don't
necessarily want to get down you know
I'm saying I'm not playing game right
you don't have to buy it yeah you
literally you believe I just want to do
opulence and I just want to do for Joe I
just wanna do a plinth and it's a la
carte row like that's great or cyberpunk
came out in March I'm gonna play that
for three months okay season of opulence
came back I'll do that for the summer
mmm pick your peace meal or if you yeah
and that's the thing too is like you got
to think about if you do shadow keep
there's three more beyond that that
you'll be able to buy and that would be
30 if you want to skip one of those well
they'd be 20 or if you buy them all for
25 really you're getting one for half
off I mean in the grand scheme still 10
if you want to skip and just do ten
bucks later do it yeah yeah facts facts
about the wily seed plays I yeah I'm
gonna cyberpunk training to sounds every
song is gonna be crazy
oh that's why that's the 1i waiting for
big time I don't know how were ever
gonna have enough time to play these
games anymore fine now September is a
prime example have we do not have enough
we're overloaded with slate
entertainment options between 14 like so
many movies all the TV shows you don't
have time to watch and then huge deep
hundred our games multiple of them
coming out in the same month you got a
you got I mean it's really hard to be
like an entertainment creator because
you got to try and keep your audience
and it's not easy but little influxes of
this or you know the seasons not the
whole you know it's not the best
that next one comes back BAM come back
and get that ten bucks
yep so I mean he dropped a lot which is
crazy they're out at PAX right now doing
their thing which is cool they were we
were waiting to hear about the PvP stuff
ish I don't know if that's gonna get
dropped in a different way maybe there's
a reveal at PAX that happens I don't
know when PAX actually goes on is it
just over the weekend basically oh yeah
it's kind of like a weekend event yeah
it's like four days like basically
usually runs like Thursday through
Sunday
yeah so I thought we had the something
about like a crucible thing and then me
I think that must just be about like
we're getting crucible labs we're
getting elimination I think it's more
just maybe a visual confirmation of all
that stuff I don't know if there's it's
called life management thanks vagabond
Oh for the wise words there he's
hilarious well yeah I mean I don't know
I read through all this and I was like
bring it on seriously yeah what's a
serious mess serious stuff serious
serious stuff and we've got that we kind
of glanced over widows court Twilight
gap man oh dude I can't wait D give me
some more d1 maps ooh dad feels right
there those bashful eels no whittles
tidal pull you pull you out a scout
rifle
- but widows courts got range and lanes
and mmm-hmm-mmm was fun I was like that
was I'm not the best sniper but when you
do hit your Snipes feels good oh yeah
absolutely like I was playing with that
beast mode guy in comp but there was
like one match he's like dude those
Snipes you got that last match we're
like they clutched up was like I did
something honestly that's one of those
things that is it's a weird thing to
describe but when you play with people
above your level it it takes you up bro
you learn you see strategies you watch
and you just like okay it only helps it
improve your game big-time yeah I gotta
get down with this man I don't get ya
back back part of this action I'm not
that good I gotta be around the right
people I have matches I've been doing
like I am on this like roller coaster of
getting my butt whooped and crushing
somebody else like it is all over the
place gambits the same way a hundred two
zero zero to a hundred
smoked on both matches mop the floor
with them it's it is so all over the
place sometimes I do wonder about how
the matchmaking goes but I will say this
ever since your boy got truth it's not
even fair we care but right now it your
gambit is I'm so unless I am not that
good a gamble
I got truth I'm in there invading like I
know what I'm doing and it is so
aggressive for all my people like look
at the person pull hard off to the side
and fire so it has a big arc to get to
them it's just stupid got my delirium so
I'm finally happy
Thanks yeah I gotta finish up some
bounties for rhetorics I should get that
over the weekend and then after that I'm
kind of hands-off ish outside of what we
got a knock out but I mean there's great
there's not a lot that's like I really
need to do this mm-hmm I don't need
valor I don't need glory I don't need
iron banner I got my soul I'm going by
pure freedom luck mm-hmm
but also it's a time for a lot of people
if you did just grind out on solstice
and you're like I have played so much
I'm like most blood shot like yeah
solstice will break you
solstice you need a vacation yeah like I
said the only reason why I just got
caught up with a whole bunch of things
being close to completion and I'm like
you know what let me just get it done
because I was literally out to sold out
but I was like to you know having this
close let me just knock these things out
and I'm just in this mold to hurry up to
finish it and then like do exactly what
you're doing that use this precious
downtime before shadow key to take care
of all the games and other things to see
what's going on we know what's gonna
happen with shadow key drops life ends
your other game stop so that's what's
gonna happen well I'm trying to set
things up where I might actually be off
for a few days around shadow keep for a
change
just set it up to park my butt right
here you guys are on Twitch wanna throw
those mullahs up you guys will know
where to find us if her shadow keep it
yeah we're gonna be trying to get some
guests on so
guess that we are working on trying to
get on we will potentially be shifting
the time and the podcast more to an
evening for one let this man get some
sleep so he's not a zombie he powers
through like no other but I know by the
time you are done you like probably fall
asleep on the way down to the pillow
yeah
now you keep my energy levels up face um
I guess things hey that's right I try to
do my best
keep it going keep help help the vampire
out when I do my rants and I'm like all
right I'm waiting that's like the one
elephant in the room is Borderlands 3
how long have a tale do you think that's
gonna have it's an October 1st I'll just
be a real be you know it's great it's a
great game you know I'm glad you know
shadow keep got delayed bro I'm glad
because we get to appreciate a you know
here's the other thing like is next week
I'm hearing phenomenal things and the PC
port is spectacular you gonna have to
get down years Oh yep that's that's like
that's a that's a bullet hole in my
gaming is a main game pass bro game
paths ultimate you're in free what was
it five bucks or anything doubt what
kind of kind of sort of free well let's
PC it up you know Eddie's got cross-play
remnant oh yeah you got control yeah oh
I actually managed to play both of those
I got two other people that really want
me to play Borderlands for at least a
couple weeks and boy leans 17 yes you
doing remnant wakes you remnant and if I
can get through a remnant couple times
feel pretty good control I heard might
be like 1012 hours so just weird cool
story though so if I can do both of
those and then Borderlands that's more
than I've played most years so I'm mad
that control is doing well because I was
hoping it would be average my tough
choice as I see that or anxious
nah both of these games not gonna play
these games both from with the Salo we
got the picture so you know let me go
after training you know switch whatever
whatever so when I'm seeing these
reviews for controller I'm like oh come
on
this game is ridiculous okay what it's
our games in Seine and so this is August
and we oh my god yeah this is August and
it already started September is worse so
much worse ridiculous but today has been
awesome guys thank you very much we are
wrapping up August we're next to a month
away from shadow keep we've got a lot of
information I don't know how much more
we're really gonna get cuz I think
you've got a lot actually got a lot you
know we've got a lot mm-hmm
well thank you for coming in uh love lo
I can't even let lo haré me a level oh
I'm probably butchering that one faces
in here we saw Spidey we got my mark
here's back so I use that the other day
thank you guys all for coming in chat
was great the ninja and the cheetah
appreciate it greatly already know even
the cops before that podcast got it
gotta get it once gotta get the streak
continues
spidey-sense I like that almost I'm
seeing us live Wow they get spicy so
yeah thank you guys very much if you
want to wrap up tom where you out what
you got going on this weekend and then
I'm gonna go find somebody else for us
to raid so you guys hang tight we'll get
more things to talk about
oh you guys over to say no to rage no
doubt a man lone oh yeah but you already
know it I'm Nord Cognito the game yeah
you can feel Twitter at moored Cognito
please catch our website Lords of gaming
dotnet you boys got that fresh new
article right now about the season path
kind of stuff that we discussed and the
stuff that I reiterated here you know as
far as what's going on so please check
that out and of course I am more podcast
every Sunday is the Lord's Day 1:00 p.m.
Eastern on the iron law podcast YouTube
channel we will have the mooch returns
your Messiah as he was with us last year
great show he will be back on will be
discussing everything that's going on in
the gaming industry we talk control what
you're talking is we'd be talking a lot
of stuff man there's a lot of great game
a strain
probably talked about that so whatever
platform your rock but there be you know
PC or whether it be its PlayStation
switch Xbox come check us out with talk
game and have some fun and definitely
somebody's knees will be bent in the
realm so check us out man but yeah and
of course every Friday you already know
is the last word and like he said we've
got some guests cooking up you know we
might make some schedule changes to
accommodate we will let you guys know if
that happened and when it happens ahead
of time but I appreciate the support is
good to see this thing grow and yeah man
and also eat
he's got the audio going you got the
anchor poppin yeah you guys thank you
all for the listens by the way that just
keeps growing every week over week you
guys are awesome so thank you guys just
brain them stat to throw out there and
thank you guys so far since this thing's
been up on audio 3600 plays of all of
our podcast so far
thank you guys that's that's freaking
awesome and it keeps going there's no
guys man and if also thanks to the arm I
want to shout out you know the the
Twitter presence I've been seeing a lot
of positive comments for us really
appreciate it man thank you guys for
really shouting us out and you know
wishing that we get on stuff and I was
like wow this is awesome hey this is
really cool man thank you guys for that
and we just trying to grow this thing
and we appreciate those retweets and
support class work yeah and for me like
I'm gonna be putting out a couple of
videos talked about most of my thoughts
but I'll just kind of break down my
thoughts of what I recorded yesterday
most of it just about the rest of this
so about the artifact my deep dives and
thoughts seasonal ranks and I'll kind of
have my speculation as everybody who's
in a tizzy about it and all those pieces
so we've got a lot to look forward to
thank you guys hip last word pod on
Twitter cast Twitter but also of course
of course
iron Lords podcast follow this man Lord
Cognito as well i'm ebonne too so
everywhere you guys are here you know
where to find me the YouTube channels
for both of us thank you guys for
everything and it's xerte as well so you
guys know I'll get that video up in with
an hour and 43 minutes plus the time it
takes me to make it and other than that
thank you guys very much this has been
episode 71 I just keep seeing that
number climb and that's and thank you
guys it's been really cool it's been
going this long so thank you all for the
support
and for episode 71 August 30th it has
been the last word